is going to be a very significant issue
that you're going to face
that in previous times administrations
just ignored and did not enforce
senator i hear you very clearly and as i
said i will respect the law
as hhs secretary there there are
multiple grants in aid that's out there
that they'll have to be decisions made
over whether faith-based
entities can get grants or aid at the
same level as non-faith excuse me
non-faith-based
entities excuse me here's the challenge
in
some previous administrations of your
faith-based entity you were not allowed
to participate
strictly because of your faith and the
structure of that the supreme court has
now stepped in pretty clear decisions
over the past several years to make it
clear
you can't discriminate someone on the
basis of their faith
will you make sure the grant and the aid
proposals from hhs are equal for
faith-based entities and non-faith-based
entities
for the same issues again you raise the
issue
regardless of what your perspective is
right where wherever we all may fall on
these issues
at the end of the day we've got to make
sure at least i do
as the if i'm fortunate to be the
secretary of hhs i have to follow the
law
and there i will tell you that we will
make sure that we are following the law
thank you mr chairman i'd like to ask
for four different letters to be entered
into the record that folks have
sent to me and other members of this uh
committee without objection that's so
ordered
all right um our next colleague is
senator brown
on the web and i see senator daines here
so senator danes would follow senator
brown
senator brown well thank you mr sheridan
general massa good to see you thanks for
your willingness to serve
secretary of hhs thanks for your
commitment
through your whole career because i've
known you a long time to reducing health
disparities and
and prioritizing policies to address the
social
determinants of health a number of
communities in my state have passed
resolutions declaring
a racism a public health crisis i
think it's important that we we know
that the history of institutional racism
continues to impact health outcomes for
communities and
i um it's particularly important that
that you
um understand the urgent need to be
intentional about your work
and i know you will be so thank you for
that uh cincinnati is home to
uh two cdc niosh for children's
facilities national institutes of
operational safety and health
um they are unlike any facilities in the
country maybe in the world their
their focus is occupational injury
repetitive injury occupational health
generally toxins in the workplace all of
that
in 2015 secretary burwell announced that
hhs will be dedicating
110 million dollars to consolidate and
upgrade the current
cincinnati niosh facilities they've in
various agreed degrees of
disrepair the way cdc was a a half a
generation ago
um cdc and gao are currently undergoing
site acquisition activities i understand
both the site purchase and
a design build contract will be
finalized this spring it's moved
entirely
too slowly there was indifference or
worse from the previous administration i
my request is simple to ask if you would
work with senator portman and me to
ensure this project
continues to get the attention it
deserves from hhs
including uh the funding necessary to
stay on track
do you have my commitment to that dude
thank you thank you general
um in recent years congress and hhs have
expanded the scope of benefits
available to those who are enrolled in
medicare advantage plans without doing
the same thing for those individuals
who choose to remain in traditional
medicare we've added benefits
vision dental we remove barriers to care
like the three-day stay rule for skill
for
us skilled nursing facility care for
medicare advantage beneficiaries
but failed to extend you know that's the
more privatized medicare if you will
but fail to extend those same advantages
to those seniors that
that stay in traditional medicare plans
and those seniors typically are a little
older and a little sicker and a little
poorer
generally the growing imbalance between
the programs
concerns me greatly especially in the
medicare programs been spending more
money
per medicare advantage plan enrollees
than on people who choose traditional
medicare a relatively
recent but inexorable move in that
direction
my question uh general masetto will you
commit to using your authority to
building
to to holding private insurers
accountable and reining in those
medicare advantage
overpayments to ensure taxpayers and all
medicare beneficiaries are getting their
money's worth
senator uh you have my commitment now in
terms of uh
dealing with medicare you're right we
don't have the the
dollars to spare and to waste and so
what in this process you're trying to
strengthen and improve medicare
we have to make sure we're doing
oversight and keeping everyone
accountable and so i absolutely agree
that uh
that's going to be one of the principal
responsibilities we have we have to be
good stewards
of the uh medicare program taxpayer
dollars
and as you mentioned with this three-day
rule for post-acute care
uh there are ways that we have to make
sure that we're keeping everyone honest
and
i will make sure that there is a level
playing field
good level playing field here is so so
important
i'm in closing one one last point mr
chair general rossetta
um i'd like to i want to bring the prior
bring forward to you the whole the issue
of the priority of bringing down the
high cost of prescription drugs let me
share a story
quickly with you from a constituent in
columbus
columbus area community called
pickerington from a young man named
someone named colton
he was diagnosed with ulcerative colitis
in 2014
with his insurance coverage changed two
years later he was forced to pay 1200
every four weeks for the infusions that
kept his disease and remission
i just want to read you his comments
briefly at the time of this cost
increase i was in college was already
feeling the financial burden
of student debt budgets for students are
already tight enough but the immense
increase in cost for my infusions
left me in a very difficult position
unfortunately with the added financial
burden for my infusions i had to choose
between affording the cost of my
infusions
or school this decision wasn't a
decision at all since i needed the
infusions to stay alive
the unreasonable price of my
prescriptions forced me to leave college
my life path he writes has been
completely altered
by expensive prescription drugs the drug
company greed i often feel like i'm
behind
all of the people my age even people
younger than i
because i've had to focus my time and my
money
on staying alive we shouldn't have to
give up on pursuing a college education
because of critical
medical debt crippling medical debt we
shouldn't have to make every financial
decision with the cost of prescriptions
and medical debt
in the back of our minds things can be
better if our leaders reign in drug
company greed and make me the needs of
patients like me the priority
that's the end of this letter um now's
the time uh
general for for meaningful reforms to
bring down
drug prices my question is simple
confirm will you commit to working with
me and other members of this committee
especially chair wyden who's been so
involved in this
to deliver real change that will make
american prescription drugs more
affordable
you have that commitment thank you
general thank you
chairman white thank you senator brown
we will be working on that senator dain
thank you chairman wyden
uh attorney general sarah i just want to
be up front and tell you i i've got
serious concerns with the radical views
that you've taken in the past on the
issue of abortion
as well as one of a very important
constitutional protection that is
religious liberty frankly a record that
shows a disregard for that
our present challenges demand an hs
secretary
is prepared to combat the coven 19
pandemic
and command a position of public trust
many montanans pro-life groups
across the country have written to say
that you've taken the most radical
positions on this very important issue
of life and
on abortion if you want to push back on
that impression i think you have an
opportunity here to try to uh to gain
some public trust
and to take a look at the record you've
had in california
and how you might uh govern
if you are approved here in washington
dc um
could you name one abortion restriction
that you might support
senator let me let me try to respond
this way um
i have tried to make sure on this
important issue for so many people where
oftentimes again we have different views
but deeply health views that i have
tried to make sure that i am abiding by
the law
because whether it's a particular
restriction
or whether it's the whole idea of
abortion
uh whether we agree or not we have to
come to some
conclusion and that's where the law
gives us
is there just to be clear is there any
line you would draw
is there just one just one restriction
as it relates to abortion so you might
support
senator you're talking to the spouse of
a uh
ob gyn who for decades has practiced
saving lives of women
and babies and i can tell you that from
the stories i've heard from carolina my
wife
i know how hard many women struggle just
to save the life of their baby
and so what i would say to you and i
know that right now as i speak
my mother has blessed me this morning as
i got ready to come here and last night
i know when she prayed the rosary as she
does every day
uh every evening with my aunt that she
said a prayer and included me in there
well there's you know part of it's the
battle for those who don't have a voice
which are the little babies
um well and you didn't answer the
question about any even one
even one restriction on abortion um i
didn't get an answer from you let me
just throw one out there how about a ban
on the lethal discrimination of babies
who are diagnosed with down syndrome
and so senator once again if i can
simply say to you that i respect the
different views that are out there
but what's important is that it makes
sure that but
you're gonna if you confirm you're gonna
be the head of the hhs it's it's a
huge organization has profound impact
on our society how about a ban on sex
selective abortion
whether you whether the little baby is a
male or female would you say you can't
have a sex selective abortion
and i respect those who take a
particular view
my job will be to make sure that i am
following the law
there's a ban on partial birth abortion
i know that question came up yesterday
is that
yes or no would you support a ban on
partial birth abortion
again senator you're asking questions
which we'll touch on aspects
that i know have different views and
what i can say is that i will make sure
that i'm respecting the law on those
issues
you've repeatedly intervened in court to
revoke an important religious exemption
to obamacare's contraception mandate
from people like the little sisters of
the poor in order of catholic nuns that
serve the poor
and are most vulnerable and they have
won at the supreme court
as hhs secretary would you commit to
defending the existing regulatory
exemptions to the conscious have to
mandate
or you seek to eliminate the exemption
protecting the little citizens of the
poor
from crippling government fines but as
you may as you mentioned the supreme
court issued
a ruling we'll make sure as if i'm
fortunate to become secretary of hhs
that we will abide by the law as it
stands and now with this ruling from the
sec uh from the
you would defend the existing mandate
then per the court i will i will defend
the law
and support the law that's in place
according to cdc data they've been
comparing states and territories montana
is ranked near the top for
administration of vaccine but we fall
near the bottom
for first doses allocated by the federal
government that's why our congressional
delegation
wrote to president by expressing
frustration that montana isn't getting
its fair share of vaccines i'm concerned
hhs is neglecting to reward states like
montana
that could administer at least three
times the number of doses
being delivered currently do you believe
hhs should provide
additional vaccines to states like
montana for example
who've been able to quickly and
efficiently get vaccines in the arms of
people who want them
senator we applaud states that are are
moving forward and being diligent in
getting their
people protected and i know that
president biden has made the commitment
to have
all the vaccines that we'll need from
throughout the country and what i can
commit to you is to make sure we're
working with you and the folks in
montana to make sure that
the vaccines are there for the people of
your state when they need them
and doing that for the same the same way
for all the people in this
in this country we want to make sure
we're not missing anyone
and that's where this issue of pockets
of population thank you for that
appreciate that answer
um last question you're on record for
pushing for allowing illegal immigrants
to receive
taxpayer-funded health care and for
decriminalizing illegal entry in the
united states
this coupled with president biden's
radical plan for granting citizenship to
those who were here illegally would
potentially lead to hundreds
of thousands if not potentially millions
more people flooding into our country as
you know
in 2016 california passed a law
requiring covered california to apply
for section 1332 waiver
to allow illegal immigrants to purchase
health insurance through the marketplace
this waiver was withdrawn
after president trump's election my
question is this will you attempt to use
the waiver authority
contain the affordable care act to grant
health care benefits to illegal
immigrants
senator but i can tell you that where
the law
as it stands now as as i see it
it does not allow those who are uh
unauthorized in this country
to receive taxpayer paid benefits except
in very rare circumstances
and it will be my job to make sure that
we are following and enforcing the law
and i can commit to you that that's what
we will do thank you
senator bennett thank you mr chairman
uh please turn to another it's very nice
to see you mr attorney general welcome
back to washington
and i want to turn to what was also
called a radical plan
and that was the affordable care act
which has made massive strides
in providing health care to 20 million
americans protecting people
with pre-existing conditions from
discrimination
and a lot of other things that have
become the norm in this country
like staying on your parents health
insurance until you're 26 something
you couldn't do before the affordable
care act was passed i think we need to
build on the affordable care act
and use the medicare system to provide a
true public option
and it's something that the president
has also talked about on his campaign
i believed in it when we passed the aca
to begin with the votes weren't here to
do
it i think it's become very clear during
the course of the pandemic
that nobody is served by having people
that don't have primary access
or to access the primary health care
because you can see
in the numbers in the pandemic what's
happened to this country
versus some other places last august
president
then a candidate biden was speaking to
one of my
constituents from colorado laura packard
who was told told the vice president at
the time that
um she was literally receiving
chemotherapy on the day that
there were some folks here trying to
repeal the affordable
care act and she asked her what he was
going to do for people like her and for
you know people in america and he told
her quote we're going to provide a
medicare-like
option as a public option he went on i'm
going to protect you like i try and
protect my own family and i promise you
that
it was a powerful moment for all of us
who are watching and
yesterday senator tim kaine and i uh and
some of my colleagues on this committee
reintroduced the medicare x choice act
to create a true public option
increasing choice for consumers
starting in rural areas reducing health
care costs and increasing affordability
and quality
of health insurance we work to ensure
that our updated legislation aligns
with president biden's plan including
plans offering primary care services
without cost sharing fixing the family
glitch to increase access to premium
support
and ensuring that the cap on premiums
for everyone above 400 percent of
federal poverty level is 8.5
of their income medicare x both finishes
the work of the aca and aligns
with the president's objectives you are
uniquely situated
having been both the lawmaker and the
california attorney general
to help us get this across the finish
line and i just want to ask
what your thoughts are on on on
the commitments the president made on a
public option during the campaign and
and how we can get it across the finish
line so we can finally
fulfill the promise that every single
american has access to health care in
this country
senator uh you pointed out where
now president biden stood as candidate
biden and he was very strong about this
he made it very clear that
the affordable care act is a strong
foundation from which we can build
you've mentioned the public option he
made it very clear he's a supporter
of moving forward on a public option my
job will be to try to implement the
president's agenda on health care
and so i will look forward to working
with you and all of your colleagues
to try to make sure we can continue to
see more americans access health care
whether through their employer or
whether through medicaid
or whether through the affordable care
act marketplaces
we need to have those options including
the public option available
if states want to move in that direction
we will try to be
we'll work with them as best we can but
as you've said the goal here has to be
to make things even better more
affordable for americans
you know i um mr chairman i came up with
the idea
for this legislation after i was in a
meeting in jackson county colorado and
to give you a sense of
jackson county um i saw my friend from
indiana i had to start the meeting by
apologizing for how badly
i had done in the election the last time
because it is
you know there are very few democrats
there and somebody actually said oh you
actually
want a few more democrats than there
actually are but it was it was grim
but i was there and somebody said to me
you know michael
i moved back to this town it's a county
with i think fewer than a thousand
people in it
huge space but i moved back to this town
to take over the bowling alley that i
love to go to as a kid
and i'm working 50 hours a week my wife
is working 50 hours a week
neither of us has health insurance said
my
my my i've got people i want to hire but
i can't hire people
because they have to give up their
welfare to come work for me i said what
do you mean
their welfare he said their medicaid in
other words their health care so here in
america
this is after the affordable care act
was bad here we have a situation where a
small business owner and his wife are
working 50 hours a week
they can't afford health insurance folks
that would want to come work
can't come work because they have to
give up their insurance how can we
defend a system like that
and we don't need to and i think i hope
we look back at the history of all of
that
and find a way to put the partisanship
aside and actually provide the american
people with just what this is an
option they can choose they can choose
all over rural and urban colorado
it'd be a choice if you want to stay
with your private insurance stay with it
if you want a public option administered
by medicare
you can have that too and um i think
that's going to be a powerful argument
for the american people who
coming out of this pandemic want more
choices not fewer so
i'm very glad you've been nominated and
i look forward to supporting your
nomination and and working with you to
to deliver this to the american people
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
bennett senator young
mr bersera there are there are all sorts
of concerns uh by my constituents and
and uh i think every american about
getting shots into arms as quickly as
possible
uh that is uh uh my foremost uh
objective in trying to support
uh the administration uh in furtherance
of that goal
um the biden administration just
announced the launch of two new federal
programs
the federal retail pharmacy program in
the community health center's
vaccination program
this was an effort to speed up
vaccinations across the country
these programs are in addition to an
existing program which is uh the
pharmacy partnership for long-term
care program unfortunately
um these these various programs are
causing some confusion for the states
as the states aren't able to oversee and
coordinate distribution
of our already limited supply of vaccine
with uh these various entities long-term
care facilities community health centers
retail pharmacies and and
individual hoosiers are confused as well
because now they have to sign up in
multiple places
in order to become vaccinated in fact
the national government
governors association recently wrote to
the administration
highlighting this issue indicating quote
if the federal government distributes
independently of the states
to these same entities without state
coordination and consultation
redundancy and inefficiency may very
well follow
unquote i'd like to submit
two letters for the record one from the
nga and one from my home state of
indiana
uh further detailing these concerns
without objections ordered
so i bring this to your attention
because until
adequate supply is available mr becerra
the administration should be working
with states on vaccine distribution
especially since retail pharmacies and
and federally qualified health centers
are already part of many states vaccine
plans and the state of indiana has
has been making uh great strides
uh with the available vaccine to to get
into the arms of hoosiers so
um uh do you commit to working with the
states before announcing major program
rollouts
like uh the two i mentioned in the
future
and and senator you'll understand why
this is close to
my gut more than my heart because i'm a
state official right now
and we've had to administer a lot of
these programs i've had to defend many
of these programs
in our state level in court and what i
will say to you is that
if we're not doing a good job of
coordinating with our state
and local and tribal and territorial
partners then we're not doing what we
doing it as well as we can and so i am
committed to working with you to make
sure that
as we get the product out and
fortunately
president biden has made an aggressive
effort to make sure we have enough
vaccines for everyone
that we're working with all those who
have to make sure that shot actually
gets into the arm
so that's an encouraging response let me
go further sure
would you allow states like indiana who
may
well find these programs
counterproductive
to our shared goals of getting vaccine
into arms
to opt out of these federal programs
until a time where there's adequate
supply available so let me i
yeah i'm not that yet there and i hope
to be confirmed but i it'd be
tough senator be honest with you would
you consider it
absolutely we'll sit down with you and
talk if the moment i am on
in that seat i will make sure that we
are sitting together we'll go to your
office and we'll talk about this
can you conceive of a reason why you
wouldn't allow a state like indiana to
opt out of these programs
i will tell you that the president's
goals are ambitious we want to move
quickly
i can't understand why we wouldn't want
to always coordinate but i also want to
make sure it's clear
that the president has been very very uh
transparent in saying that
we want to make sure we're reaching
everyone we're doing it in a fair way
okay and we're doing it in a court you
know it makes sense i'm gonna cut you
off because
you know how this goes i get a limited
time yes um
um but i would i would hope you would
allow states like indiana to opt out
if if uh that will help us get more
vaccine in the arm of hoosiers
so 33 americans uh die
every day waiting for a life sort saving
organ transplant
we have an organ shortage in this
country and it results from
a severe lack of oversight and
accountability among government monopoly
contractors that run our organ donation
system these are known as organ
procurement organizations or opo's
the senate finance committee recently
noted that our organ donation system
has been severely underperforming for
decades
department of health and human services
finalized a rule last november that
would allow hhs to hold opios
accountable for their
performance for the first time in its
40-year
history this rule
is projected to save more than 7 000
additional lives every year it's going
to save money too over a billion dollars
annually to medicare but because this
rule was finalized in the last 60 days
of the previous administration
you know where i'm headed with this it's
currently being subjected to the biden
administration freeze on midnight
regulations
so as hs secretary uh
will you commit to implementing and
enforcing
the november 2020 opo final rule swiftly
and forcefully
as soon as a review period ends so first
i got to say thank you for the role
you've played on organ donation uh
it's critical it's not a subject
everyone wants to take on
secondly uh there's a pod the pause that
the
president put on a number of of these
rules is something that most
administrations do but i can guarantee
you that
the administration if i'm fortunate to
be uh confirmed
hhs will work quickly to try to get back
up to speed on some of these
uh different rules what i can commit to
is this is we all know we need to
increase the supply
we know we have to be fair we have to
make sure we're doing this in a way that
makes sense
and we have to do the oversight and so i
can commit to you to work with you to
make sure that
if i once i get in the chair if i'm
fortunate to be confirmed
that we will talk to you about how we
move forward with that rule
and of course your legislation as well
thank you mr train john let me also say
to my colleague and to those following
this i think these are
very important issues and we have had a
bipartisan inquiry going on in this
committee where
our colleague has been very actively
involved we will be continuing that it
is
um really high priority matter and
my colleague has laid out some of the
problems and we're going to
want to get into the details i believe
when the
attorney general's confirmed and i was
appreciative of his positive answers so
i thank you
let's do this um if there are
any senators waiting in the queue
on the web we will take one more before
we go and vote
and then otherwise per an agreement with
both sides we'll take a 15 minute recess
uh mr attorney general are any of my
colleagues waiting on the
web to uh
ask questions all right i gather not
so it is uh a little after four well it
will take
15 minutes and we'll have a recess and
we'll we'll be back at that at that
point
oh senator casey okay senator casey
you're out there in cyberspace somewhere
i didn't think i'd have a chance ron
terrific
okay so my job we will revise the
uh state of play here and we will hear
from senator casey and after he has
completed his questions
then we'll take a 15-minute break and
that is in accord with the wishes of
both the majority and the minority
senator casey
thanks mr chairman i think i may have
jumped ahead so this i want the attorney
general to know this
never happened before so let me use my
time wisely
mr attorney general thank you again for
your public service and your
willingness to continue public service
on behalf of the nation
uh by running a major agency of our
government that's so important these
days and that's
the department of health and human
services and i also want to thank you
for
the commitment of your family which i
know is a major commitment by any family
when you're in
public service like you've been all
these years and yours is a great
american story
i wanted to start with the issue of home
and community-based services we know
that one of the real
tragedies within the larger tragedy of
the pandemic
now that we've reached that awful awful
number of 500 000 deaths
is a high percentage of those deaths at
last count more than 170 000
residents and workers dying of the virus
who are in nursing homes living or
working in nursing homes
or other long-term care settings one way
to protect these populations with
a responsive it is i should say is with
a responsive and
robust support system that provides
quality
home and community-based services we
know that those who do this work
in the home or home and community-based
services as well as in the long-term
care setting
are front-line workers they're heroic
and
the folks who do this work support or
older adults uh in our communities and
they also support
and provide care for uh folks with
disabilities who need that help
they're often paid about twelve dollars
an hour for this essential work
most of them uh a high percentage of
them are women of color
and because these home and
community-based services are not
required under medicaid
under current law there's over 800 000
people
on waiting lists for these services 16
000 of those
in pennsylvania so we need to invest in
this
this option that we haven't really made
part of medicaid in a substantial way
other than the
the waiver program uh we need to invest
now the house
uh legislation uh their their covet 19
bill has over nine billion dollars
this is but a foot in the door but a
very important
unprecedented uh foot in the door
so i have two questions for you first
upon the passage and i'm being
optimistic here but i think it'll happen
the passage of this emergency funding
legislation
covet 19 legislation as well as the
funding for home and community-based
services will you work to distribute it
to the states as quickly as possible
you've got my commitment center thank
you
and then secondly as you know the next
um
the next matter for president biden and
vice president harris is to work on the
buildback better plan and that's another
opportunity i think for us to really
focus on this issue but provide an even
more substantial investment
in home and community-based services and
i hope you would work with us to secure
that funding
you've got my commitment again to work
with you on that
the last issue in my remaining time is
medicaid i don't have to tell you
because you've been a strong
uh supporter and a fighter to preserve
medicaid funding
medicaid in so many ways isn't some
program
it's it tells who we are it tells us
who we are and tells us whom we value
whether it's kids or or seniors or
people with disabilities
so many millions of americans 70 million
plus a last count
uh have the benefit of medicaid you you
were familiar with when we sat down
most recently and in our last hearing in
the health committee with my
uh agenda for children and the five
freedoms for america's children
i believe every child at birth if they
don't have health care coverage
should be covered by medicaid and i just
want to ask
how will you use your authority as hhs
secretary
to utilize waiver authority and other
tools to strengthen medicaid
and to help expand coverage to uninsured
or under insured americans
senator i know you know this so i'm i'm
i'm just repeating what you've already
worked on so much and that is
medicaid has the lifeline it is what's
kept so many american families from
losing all hope
and in many cases losing respect and so
i i
am absolutely prepared to work with you
and
many of your colleagues to try to do
what we can to strengthen medicaid
because
uh for so many including seniors who
have medicare
who oftentimes rely on medicaid as well
we have to make sure that we don't lose
sight of how important medicaid has
become to the entire population
and with the president's commitment to
continue to build on the affordable care
act
medicaid as you know is indispensable so
ready to work with you
on any issues especially for children
and i know my wife is applauding
uh everything you've just said to try to
make sure our children
have opportunities from the get-go
thanks so much we look forward to your
confirmation thank you senator casey
we're
calling thank you mr chairman we're
calling some audibles here and uh with
the consent of both sides we'll have
senator whitehouse and then
all other senators should know we're
going to take a 15-minute break
and then we will finish senator
whitehouse
welcome attorney general senator great
to see you and i
wish you every success in the remaining
days of your confirmation process
um i want to mention two things to you
that i've put a lot of work into
over time one is delivery system reform
in our health care system macro
we hit the medicare trust fund in 2024
and so we're gonna have to deal with
that issue between now
and then micro
rhode island has two of the best
accountable care
organizations in the country these are
primary care
provider groups doctors practices that
have got together
early signed up as acos
under the affordable care act and have
changed the way they practice and as a
result
their cost per patient is coming down
their patient satisfaction is through
the roof their outcomes are improving
and they're sending checks back to the
federal government
out of the shared savings that they've
been able to
obtain um my staff person will hand you
a little graph
that i've got a big copy of right here
which is something that i've worked on
for a while as time has gone by
in the far left here
time begins around the time we passed
obamacare
and at that point cbo
projected what federal healthcare
spending was going to look like
and their projection then is that top
line
but in fact with obamacare law
we didn't follow that trajectory costs
were actually
lower and as we've gone forward
we've experienced actual costs that are
that bottom line
and the current projection
matching that original one from
12 years ago i guess now pushes out from
where we are
now out 10 years but if you took that
same projection and put it on to where
we were before
here's this gap between what was
predicted and what we've achieved
and in the next ten years that gap is
six trillion
dollars changed
from what was anticipated at the time we
passed obamacare
and the savings in the next decade are
going to be six trillion dollars from
whatever that thing was that changed
i think that what changed
was getting away from fee for service
getting providers engaged in
accountable care organizations and the
emphasis on
quality and reducing medical errors and
dealing with uh
patients better so um
i've had my rows with the obama
administration over how they were doing
acos and i've
had my rouse with the um trump
administration
and i want to work with you to make sure
that
these organizations that are basically
breaking trail for the rest
of the health care system these
leadership acos
are getting the support and the
encouragement that they need
because when they win
we win and with medicare trust fund
starting to hit its limit looming we got
to get serious about that
and uh i don't need a long response from
you now but i want
to make sure you're aware of um
the opportunities for delivery system
reform and i know you've got some very
good acos in california as well
yes
and senator there's a response there so
i'm looking forward to working with you
on it
we will because we got work to do um
it's also
very likely a big political win-win i
don't know anybody on any side of any
aisle
in washington who doesn't want better
care
producing lower costs with happier
patients
um last point this is a bit of a
personal thing i've been working for a
long time on
on having us treat people at the end of
their lives better than we
do making sure that their choices are
respected making sure that their
capability to be at home at that time
is respected make sure that they're
pulled out of the health
hospital treadmill and they aren't
dying in intensive care units that they
don't want to be in
and shouldn't be in um we've worked with
cmmi
a lot on that and i'm hoping that we can
close out
under your leadership through the center
for medicare and medicaid innovation
a pilot program that will show that when
you treat people at the end of their
lives
with more humanity everybody's happier
and it saves money will you work with me
on that
as someone who had his father lived with
him is the last three years of his life
so that when he passed he passed in his
bed
in my home uh i absolutely i look
forward to working with you on that
you and i have had the same experience
then thank you sir and
godspeed and your com in your
confirmation thank you senator
thank god my colleague mr attorney
general take a 15-minute break
thank you
all right
[Music]
so
foreign
they got a boat
nope
[Music]
what
hey
you've got another
[Music]
sleep
okay
okay hold on